the classic Henry Ford production line
he borrowed that from herbs
slaughterhouse in Chicago but instead of
having cars on a pulley that built they
had cows on a pulley that were
dismantled he just reversed the radical
innovation of Henry Ford it's like
there's just a butcher's disassembly
line in reverse
why did you put a picture of a
half-eaten chocolate bar in your book
a really great great question that's
deep in the book when we're talking
about triggering action how we can get
people to to respond
um and the chocolate bar in itself is a
KitKat and everyone knows how you eat a
Kit Kat you eat it sort of finger by by
finger but the image that you're
referring to is an image of someone
taking a big hunk out of the end and it
sort of breaks the back you're in there
and it's a bit like self scratching
their nails down a chalkboard you're in
it's like breaking the pattern like
that's not the rule you're in we know
how to eat it we know how to eat a
KitKat and that's an example of of sort
of the brain's patternicity I mean we
love we see the worlds in in we see the
world in patterns Randomness doesn't
make any sort of benefit to our our
survivals those spotting patterns and
following these systems make a lot of
sense and if we can deviate from that we
can help people to sort of write it
um so so the chocolate bar in in
question leads itself to a wonderful
piece of behavioral design by a designer
called louvremes who created a light
switch and the intention of the light
switch was to encourage to sort of nudge
people to to switch the lights off and
and he did this by creating a light
switch that when the lights are off it
makes a beautiful zebra pattern but as
soon as you switch the light on it
breaks the pattern it's a bit like bite
at the end of a KitKat it's just not how
it's meant to be so you forever sort of
feeling this sense of discomfort and are
inclined to turn the lights off again so
that's the that's why there's an image
of a half eaten chocolate bar in the
book what job does evolution have in the
world of marketing and consumer Behavior
plays a huge role and I think in two
fronts one in in understanding
um that much of what we're seeking to
influence us has evolved in its nature
desire status all of these are sort of
evolutionary drivers the the path I take
uh in the in the book evolutionary ideas
is more so that ideas also evolve just
as we see biological evolution that
adapts and and some solutions Prevail
and some become extinct and we can see
patterns in these Solutions in biology
we can also see these patterns in ideas
and if you understand
um the the patterns and you understand
the solutions that those patterns
provide us then we can draw upon them to
be more efficient in our in our
marketing and and more creative in in
our marketing unbelieved too I quite
like the Insight that novel problems
don't require novel Solutions there's
this quote from Thomas Edison that says
your idea needs to only be original in
its adaptation to your problem which is
lovely because you think there are a lot
of
cross-category solutions that somebody
in an airline has come up with that
could be used by a person that's trying
to start a cleaning business or whatever
it might be and um yeah it does seem
like there is a
pedestalization of big innovation rather
than incremental and definitely
cross-category stuff as well
absolutely and two reasons for for this
one is
um that we have a sort of a
proportionality we have this assumption
that big problems require big Solutions
um if we hear in the in the physical
world if we hear a loud bang we assume
that it required a loud sort of a large
input by which to make the bank
um a wonderful I think it's a 60 study
but it was looking at crabs players and
casinos where you roll the dice and they
found that if people needed a high
number they were more likely to roll the
dice harder and if you needed a low
number you roll it softly really lovely
example of proportionality so this
assumption that it's great hey it's why
we thought it's so hard for us to
believe that mosquitoes can cause
something as catastrophic as yellow
fever how can something so small cause
something so big but in the world of
ideas and psychology it certainly can
big big sort of outcomes can be caused
by small Solutions and that's a big
argument for sort of nudge Theory and
that's been written a lot in Innovation
and Behavioral Science but when I get
really interested in is that a solution
or a problem that might feel field novel
to you is likely not novel to someone
else in another category and as you say
Chris we're so blinded by the industry
that we're in and often the category
tropes that we're defined by that we
don't look outside the category and and
we've needed a sort of a bit of
connective tissue to help us to go there
I mean what's why would
Castrol motorol ever seek advice or
inspiration from Gatorade or Powerade
right and I I've worked with with with
business like castor oil in the past
looking at engine lubricants and we do
creative reviews of Shell Helix and
Valvoline and all the lubricant
categories to see what they're doing
creatively that year but we'd never look
at Powerade but if we understood that
both are in the same that they're faced
with the same challenge we need to
convince people to pay a premium for a
product that they can't see is actually
working you know it's it's doing its
magic behind closed doors because of
some magic secret ingredient whether
that's an iron 4 molecule for Powerade
or magnatec for Castrol we're talking
about the same human challenge here so
let's let's give ourselves an excuse to
sort of expand our scope of inspiration
outside the category that we're in is
that the superpower of being an agency
that works outside of companies a
marketing department that's held within
a particular business itself is going to
be much more siled
for me that is and that's I mean that's
one of the most enjoyable Parts I think
of working in an agency but I remember
years ago
um and I can't remember the exact names
for the the challenge but my old boss
Mark serif that um strategy um head of
Ogilvy in Australia and we're working on
Uncle Toby's oats right so it's like
classic Australian down-to-earth oats
and and we sat down I remember where
we're sitting I don't remember the
problem but he said I've seen the same
problem for Jaguar and I remember when
when I was very Junior into the business
I thought well firstly well this guy's
worked on Jaguar how awesome is that but
the fact that he had the exposure to so
many Brands and challenges that he could
connect to challenge for rolled oats
with one that he's seen for for Joshua
premium sports cars and and I think
that's
um that's a a blessing of being in an
agency but it's also something I think
if you make it part of your job to seek
sort of cross-category challenges and
cross-category solutions so you can
bring them to spaces that they otherwise
wouldn't belong and that goes back to
what I was speaking about that that
connective tissue what helps us to to
define the area of exploration and to
justify why we can bring that solution
into a category that it might never be
seen before
to draw this across to Evolution I think
you make a parallel between Gatorade and
Castrol and dolphins and sharks the fact
yes dolphins are mammals
yes yes and sharks are fish but both of
them independently Came Upon the dorsal
fin the things right at the top I don't
know what it does presumably it's steer
is that what they steer with stabilizes
stabilizes the shark and the dolphin and
you're right so both both sort of two
categorically different species of
animal
under the same environmental constraints
right the need to survive swim fast
capture prey in water could what the
term has convergently evolved on the
dorsal fin
um so we can start to see two different
species have done this in nature how
might we see two different species of
organization do that when faced with the
same challenge it's not water but it
could be triggering action like we've
spoken about it could be enhancing
loyalty this is that and what sort of
constraints does that pose us and
therefore what what have we convergently
stumbled upon in in other Industries and
categories the issue that you have in
evolution is that the animals can't look
at the features that other animals have
and said oh that looks that look that
looks great yeah I'll have a bit of that
whereas obviously in business and
marketing you can do that we can yeah
precisely so an example from my industry
I run nightclubs for a very long time
and one of the things that you're trying
to do there is
generate
excitement anticipation
engagement
trust social cohesion status all of that
from basically nothing
Rory's idea of alchemy this is whatever
one step before that is this is me
creating something from nothing this is
like Big Bang Theory because every
different venue is doing the same thing
no matter how much you try and dress up
nightlife it is people getting drunk in
a room to music that's it and there is
you can change the price points and
change the music and change The Branding
and do the whatever and what we found
this was an Insight I got from
evolutionary psychology actually the
fact that humans are anticipatory beings
and a lot of the time it seems like we
enjoy our anticipation of the event
sometimes more than the actual event
itself so what we started to do
in advance of freshers week when all of
the new students would arrive we would
bring out these really protracted
um launch sequences let's say that we're
about to release a new event we've got
this new event that's coming up and it's
going to be fun we would do something
big is coming teaser eight weeks before
the event then maybe the venue that it's
going to be at or the day that it's
going to be on seven weeks before and
then there would be a full release video
that's coming and people would know when
the full release video was coming and
that just this really drawn out launch
procedure and then in the build up to
that as well we might release the room
one DJs and the room two DJs and then
we're gonna have this thing and this
thing and this thing and I found that it
really generated excitement and
anticipation out of nowhere and that's
something that I've drawn across for the
podcast as well now that I apply that so
this is cross-category two for me I
guess if I have a big guess coming up
let's say that I'm bringing Jordan
Peterson on the show I'll tell people
that I'm gonna record with him two
months before he comes on the show and
then there'll be a photo from behind the
scenes and then there'll be a countdown
timer that's going to happen until the
episode goes live and stuff like that
people need stuff to look forward to and
this is for anybody that's trying to
release anything whether you're a
personal trainer that's releasing a new
plan online or whatever
I really really think that the power of
a protracted build up sequence to it
really as long as you don't do it too
frequently because then you get burned
out and it starts to seem a little bit
sort of tarnished yep yeah but if you
use it I would say maximum of once per
six months I reckon that you can get
away with that kind of frequency and it
just
builds engagement and people are
genuinely brought in they're like oh
this is kind of a narrative it's sort of
like a soap opera and I know what's
going on and I'm excited it's that's my
uh equivalent example
and you and you're right and and
neuroimaging Studies have looked at the
brain's experience of pleasure and
actually the anticipation of is just as
valuable it lights up our brain just as
much as the receiving of the reward
right and it's why Concepts like
variable reward are so important that
sometimes you win and sometimes you
don't because it's actually about The
Hunger for the for the for the next for
the next bit of of success another way
to think of it might be what what helps
you and I love this sort of conjuring
value out of out of nowhere or finding
something that speaks volumes that is
that that needs not sort of be be
written in longhand and that's where
sort of signaling can can help too like
what's the what's the powerful signal
that speaks that says everything you're
in uh I explore that in the book around
trust and what you're saying is is my
money going to be do I trust that this
is a genuine a genuine Big Night Out is
this where actually everyone in the unit
is going to go am I going to be stuck at
that because this is a big choice to
make right
um so it's really about endearing trust
and and and there are wonderful examples
of of
lateral signals that you can draw upon
whether it's canaries going down coal
mines that signal the fact that there's
pollute sort of toxic air under
underground before the miners all the
way through to Van Halen and putting a a
clause in there in their Rider that the
band had a clause for that the setup of
their of their of their concerts that
covered everything from the lighting to
the tuning of the guitar and just to
make sure that the the band promoters
and the people setting up had followed
the rules explicitly let me give you my
pause let me let me give you my favorite
um band Rider now I want to say it was
Red Hot Chili Peppers but it might be
somebody else
so people that aren't used to live shows
might not know this but there's
typically two riders that a artist will
have one will be the tech Rider and the
other will be the hospitality Rider Tech
Rider is all of the specifics about the
distance that they need to be and the
type of ampage and the staging and the
lighting and the hospitality Rider is
exactly as it says it's we need two
ounces of the best local weed and we
need four bottles of champagne and we
want a fruit bowl and we want blah blah
blah anyway in the
Hospitality Rider this particular artist
had put that they wanted a bowl of M M's
but they wanted none of the blue ones in
they wanted all of the blue ones taking
out and what they did was they used the
blue m m test as a rough heuristic for
how much they needed to scrutinize the
rest of the rider because if they went
in the first thing that they would look
at in the hospitality room was are there
any blue M M's in the bowl if there were
no blue M M's in the bowl they can
probably relax because if the guys have
taken blue M M's out they're going to
have the right amps out front they're
going to have the right video screen
so cool so smart genius and it was and
then that's that's it it's um the
example I'll speak is Van Halen and they
wrote it as a clause go in and and it
means that you can see one thing and it
says everything I don't have to bother
looking at anything else a good mate of
mine
um sells wedding dresses and he told me
we've just started like when we send
people the dress we've just given them
like gloves to like handle it with and I
love like just white gloves that
probably cost about 50p for a pair of
white gloves when you when you buy them
on mats and for me that's just such an
awesome piece of of marketing that just
says wow this is amazing material don't
touch this not wearing gloves and it's
simple things like that that again we
can look at a canary in a coal mine we
can borrow from a Van Halen Rider we can
look at gloves in a in a wedding dress
package and think well what's the
example of that for a big nine out I
mean how much like what's the what's the
the uh I won't try and tap dance on the
front here but it's like what's the the
police investigation that's ongoing from
the year before
well I mean what you want an example of
what we could use and what a lot of
clubs have used in the past is uh
slowing entry to extend the queue a
queue is a hard to fake signal of
popularity it's a yes social status
amplifier I guess and as people walk
past they go oh bloody hell look at this
look at the size of that I mean there's
got to be something and we always take
photos and you make sure that there's a
photo of the queue because and obviously
people then do cue packing which is to
make the queue thinner you can actually
take it from a four wide Cube to a three
wide key or a two and a half wide cue
which will actually extend it out and if
you never if you take the photo exactly
from the side you can't see how deep it
is so it's all manner of [ __ ] that's
going on in an effort again it's about
trust again it's about trust and and
providing social it's like a testimonial
on an Amazon website it's like a
five-star rating it's like thousands of
that helps in in gender trust and and I
mean filling restaurants from the front
windows back you know and so you're
walking past they look busy like these
are things that these are things things
that we've done intuitively for eons in
nightclubs in restaurants on on online
discount stores but if we understand
that the term for that or the the the
the the codified idea is social proof or
social Norm or if we're talking about a
brown m m Clause being a signal then we
can start to help to sort of again
Define the era of investigation that we
should explore and for me that's what
Behavioral Science has done it's given
us this this language this codification
that can help us more easily navigate
evolved ideas once we can see them then
the challenge is missing them it becomes
an Affliction you start to sort of see
these examples everywhere
I flew back from Rome a couple of days
ago with my mum and one of the things
that I was looking at was the printed
ticket
that I had and I I a lot of people would
be checking in online but if you do end
up getting a printed ticket the volume
of information that's on there is
absolutely insane and I saw in your book
that someone had simplified that by
creating a sleeve that you slot the
ticket into and it refines down all of
this information and it creates a little
windows and over the windows are gate
boarding time seat number perhaps
something like that first off I do need
to ask the question of why in a world
where you get an iPhone in a case that
has no instruction manual and no nothing
else you know it's really the entire
process has been refined and it's
beautiful why it is that all of this
information needs to be printed on a
piece of ticket yeah it seems completely
stupid but I like the idea of the
simplification that
but it's a halfway point I mean there's
a there's a there's been a lot on online
recently about sort of human-centric
plane tickets and how we might change
them and provide imagery because I mean
airports are a wonderful context for
Behavioral scientists because you can
never assume that language is a constant
you're speaking to people under stress
and pressure yeah where our sort of
attention resources are channeled so
it's a really a really wonderful space
um but I love that example as as a as a
hack I mean it's Midway point but I use
that in the book as an example again as
just like the dolphin and the shark have
converged upon the same solution you uh
the the the the image above that in the
book is of a um of a remote controller
for a TV that someone's probably gone
around to their Nan's house who keeps
turning on the Korean news and wondering
how on Earth can I get back to BBC one
and and they've literally just taped
over all the buttons not to use so
they've simplified the remote control as
a bit of a hack
um and Katara always did it on purpose
and so in two different
Industries addressing the challenge of
complexity reduction they've sort of
convergently evolved in the same
solution and I it's you you stumble
across these in in in in in lots of
different Realms and it's um it's a fun
space
what was the problem with Google Glass
well the problem with Google Glass I
think is there were there were more hung
up with the the the ability of
integrating technology that they missed
the the some of the Social Challenges
that they would be faced with not being
able to see what the person in front of
you might be looking at or exploring I
sort of Quip in the book like it just
takes one one trip to the bathroom live
streaming a trip to the urinal and
that's the end of that's the end of
Google Glass so it was sort of very
focused on on on specs and Engineering
Solutions and the wonders of technology
that have failed to address some of the
the the the larger challenges of our
evolved psychology of privacy of of
trust of purpose what's interesting with
Google Glass I think once you've started
to sort of shift it from being an
all-encompassing social tool to a
purposeful production Aid like so I
think Google Glasses now or similar
Technologies used in production roles
um it's it's starting to spike interest
again giving it a sort of a clearly
defined role so you can address that the
technology is still valuable if you give
it a purpose
um and so that's one and certainly in
the early days of Google Glass that that
trip them up what are people using it
for in production
I think they're using it to look at
um in I've written an article about sort
of
um like car manufacturing so they can
see
um that they're able to identify parts
and order parts on the spot it's it's
this is to be used for that outcome
um then people are more comfortable
wearing it for a shorter period of time
for for a clear outcome
didn't you guys do something in
Connecticut where you were trying to
reduce people chopping their fingers off
and dropping heavy stuff on their feet
that was in a warehouse or something as
well
that's right I was in a big a big
Factory in Connecticut
what was that what do you do yeah well
so that was
um so we're looking at it was safety it
was safety as a as a as a key challenge
um and and it's one of the examples is a
great for me it's a great example of an
evolved idea
um one of the problems when we move into
into factories and Factory safety is
that we're talking about individuals who
work long shifts over a long amount of
time with what is often High repetition
work
um so every time we went to a factory I
think someone received like a a 30-year
Milestone so we're talking about like
people who are working in the same
Factory for a long time doing quite
specific tasks and the challenge with
safety and risk taking is the more
familiar you are within an environment
the more risks you take you sort of
switch off a little bit I think a third
of car accidents occurred a mile from
your home I mean we could all sort of
identify that we just we're already like
halfway sort of taking the tie off and
and and and getting ready for we sort of
our brain switches off uh and this is a
problem obviously in factories when
irrespective of your familiarity that
circular source is still going to chop
off your fingers
um so what we actually borrowed from so
that the step to the side was some
insights around boxes
um and uh actually the the Rio Olympics
were the first Olympics to ban men from
wearing headgear in boxing because they
found actually men are more likely to
put themselves in a vulnerable position
more likely to actually experience a
concussion if you had a headgear on so
they changed the policy in Rio to
actually remove the headgears and in in
the recent Commonwealth Games that
watched again and and the men didn't
have have headgear on
um so what we needed to do actually is
pose a a challenging question to heads
of health and safety rather than saying
how can we keep your workers safe the
question was how can we make your
workers feel at greater risk feel a bit
more exposed right if you could get
someone to feel more exposed you're sort
of naturally more likely to take care of
yourself so what we did was develop a
series of of personal protective
equipment that had so if we're looking
at gloves we created a set of gloves
that had skeletons on the outside so you
could see just it it removed moved the
the
um
the sense of your fingers being an
extension of the tool and a reminder
that it is a vulnerable's extension of
you
um and and we ran some experiments
working in safety is a fascinating area
that is like I think there's a lot of
work for psychology and creativity and
safety it's just a space that sometimes
you would never expect Ogilvy to be in
in in in in these kinds of spaces but
there's a huge role for us
um and we found that
um people wearing in this experimental
Paradigm people wearing
um gloves were more likely to feel
vulnerable so we're able to have a
correlation between vulnerability and
risk-taking so those that wore the
gloves were more likely to feel
vulnerable
um and those who wore the gloves were
felt um a a greater risk of of cuts from
like low level injury like a box cutter
for example which sort of makes sense if
you're looking at a circular saw you're
still going to chop your fingers off
it's not gonna it's not you're in but
actually it sort of we had a medical
grade significance looking at at
different injuries compared to just
normal hands and compared to normal
gloves so it's again a nice small shift
borrowed from boxing that we can bring
into into safety what about humpback
whales you looked at them
humpback whales we looked at so humpback
whales is is an example in in the book I
explore of biomimicry
um if I'm talking about the the same
example Chris tell me if not so humpback
whales
um have been a a piece of inspiration
for a business called whale power
um so whale power is an organization
that have found that you can create wind
turbines that increase their lift and
reduce the drag if you borrow from the
shape of humpback whale fins that have
these things called tubals on them they
have these little bumps
um so it's a lovely example of the field
of biomimicrying we mentioned before
that
um animals can't look at each other and
go oh I like a bit of those feathers
like oh I could do some damage with that
beak if only if only I had that big they
can't do it but we can you know in so
biomimicry is a whole field that looks
at borrowing stealing from evolved
biology in nature and adapting it to
human problems whether that's a wind
turbine like a humpback whale whether
that's looking at mosquito probinski to
make pain-free needles whether no way is
that what they did it's cool man and
looking at the hair of rabbits to create
air cooling systems more efficient air
cooling systems
um so it's one of those what I mean
there's a deep Vortex if you get into it
but it's it's super cool and and and for
me discovering biomimicry was the
trigger for the book
because I thought it's a biomimicry in
design in architecture all the way back
to velcro being inspired by the Spurs um
on on a dog
yeah yeah so I always forget the name of
the gentleman who walking his dog every
day and kept having to to remove the
Spurs look to them under the microscope
and and invented Velcro so all these
things that feel like groundbreaking
revolutionary Innovation right
um is actually an adapted solution
um the the the classic Henry Ford
production line was just a
um he he borrowed that from a
slaughterhouse in Chicago but instead of
having cars on a pulley that built they
had cows on a pulley that were
dismantled he just reversed it and again
it's like the the the radical innovation
of Henry Ford it's like there's just a
butcher's disassembly line in Reverse so
biomimicry is is a is a big stepping off
point for for evolutionary ideas but
again instead of borrowing from
biological Solutions like the hair of a
jackrabbit at all the the beak of a
kingfisher to make the the shinkansen
500 are more more efficient going
through through tunnels we look at
evolved psychological Solutions so we
look at the the cognitive realm and what
we can borrow from that what was the
problem with the bullet train before
they fixed it
so the problem with the bullet train was
actually a a sound problem
um so the challenge was to
um reduce the time that and this is the
shinkansen five the shinkansen line that
stretches between Tokyo and Osaka so the
challenge was set to reduce the time
that it took the train to to to pass
that distance they had
um experimental cars that could actually
drive fast enough to manage it but the
faster the cuts went the more loud the
the more noise they produced
um so it became an auditory challenge
not not a speed challenge
um so uh there are two main main
problems on machine consent the first
was a part of the train known as the
pantograph so it connects the train to
the wise overhead and as the train
increased its speed it gave a sort of a
loud whooshing sound because of the
turbulence created by these sort of
essentially one of wings on top so what
they did uh and a Gentleman called EJ
net katsu um was in charge of the of the
of the program
um and he was a fortunately an avid bird
watcher so fascinated with birds and
fascinated with engineering and these
two loves came together on this project
so to reduce the sound of the on the
pentograph what they did was borrow from
the owl so the feathers of an owl so the
owls an nocturnal Predator it's evolved
to be able to sort of swoop down in
darkness and it's done its prey in
Virtual silence so it's and it does this
because of what's known as micro
serrations on its feathers so if you
imagine sort of small serrations on the
feathers that chop up the turbulence so
instead of having this large washing
sound now you created these micro
turbulences that dissipate at the sound
so essentially they created micro
serrations on the pantograph and the
second bird of influence on the
pantograph was the adeli penguin so it's
that's what's known as a spindle shape a
bit like a football you know those tiny
penguins that you often see sort of
trying to escape a leopard seal that's
an odelli and they borrowed from the
shape of the adeli of of to to shape the
pentograph and and address that specific
issue but the second problem on on the
shinkansen was
um the many tunnels that exist on the
line so again a bit like a a shark and a
dolphin have to address the
environmental constraint of water this
train needed to address the
environmental constraint of like a
series of tunnels how can we penetrate a
series of tunnels without creating
what's known as a tunnel boom it's a bit
like a shot of a gun a pistol being
fired and in this instance that this is
where they borrowed from the Kingfisher
so the Kingfisher beak has evolved over
a millennia to have a really interesting
sort of diamond shape so it's got a
really smooth
um angle from the the sort of the head
to the tip of the beak but it does so in
an interesting diamond shape
um and it's able to because of this it's
able to sort of go from the air to the
water to stand its prey I think it's a
substance of 800 times denser with
without it without an issue so by again
adapting the shape of the Kingfisher
beak onto the shinkansen they overcame
the challenge of the of the tunnel booms
so it's a and and I love that story
again it's a classic example of
biomimicry but it shows that that we can
do this on purpose
um but the the issue with this narrative
is that if it wasn't for the gentleman
EJ net katsu that might not have
happened I mean someone who was who was
sort of deep into to his understanding
of birds how can we make this more
systematic so it's not just so we were
able to link if you've got a if you've
got a challenge with aerodynamics here
is a battery of solutions that you can
explore that address this
whether we have time or or interest to
explore but the next stepping stone then
is is looking at systematic innovation
of evolutionary Solutions and that story
um is a is an engineering story
um and a Gentleman called generic
outschula who was a Soviet inventor
um was quickly sort of snapped up by the
the Russian Navy in the stalinist period
um to work in their Innovation happen
and and essentially was looking at
patents all day going through the the
naval Innovation Hub and said all things
none of these as are Innovations you
mean and these are these are all just
similar solutions to problems in
different different parts of the Navy
and he since then worked with some
colleagues to assess 200 000 patents and
identified them on their level of of
inventiveness and found that as little
as one percent is sort of true
innovation
for what out Schuler did in his model
Tris
um was start to then map out these
patterns of solutions so just as you
could have
species of animals that are codified by
the presence of a spinal cord or warm
blood or gills he started to do it with
engineering Solutions so one inventive
principle is the concept of a nested
doll a bit like a a classic Russian doll
and if you imagine that then you can
start to think of a telescopic camera
lens is an example of a nested doll a
retractable tape measure is an example
of a nested doll and they'll polish that
has the brush that goes in the bottle is
an example of a nest doll so we can
start to see these patterns of Solutions
in engineering and the final piece Chris
before I leave and I'll let you get a
word and I promise is is how you then
bring it together and so what they do in
Tris is they've created a matrix
and the Matrix the X and the y-axis look
at measurable attributes like volume
length weight
durability and
and and you can map then if I'm looking
to increase the volume of something
without increasing its size for example
then you look at at the at the at the
Matrix that'll give you nested doll so
you increase the volume without
increasing the size so you're faced with
challenges then how do I make a an
umbrella big enough to cover the human
body but small enough to fit in a
handbag and you look at that on the
Matrix and it gives you a starting point
for Innovation how do I make a
bulletproof jacket strong enough to stop
a bullet but not so heavy that people
can't wear it you look at the Matrix and
it gives you a sort of a short list of
the principles to start from and that's
what we begin to do in evolutionary
ideas again in Psychology but rather
than size and length and weight and
volume we look at things like Trust
and we look at things like
um decision making how do we how do we
how do we Aid decisions without limiting
Choice how do we how do we Trigger
action without forcing a response how do
we boost loyalty without increasing
incentives how do we improve experiences
without changing their duration and for
each similar to the truth we can start
to say well here are some psychological
principles that you should start with so
we go back to our night club conundrum
well that's maybe fundamentally a trust
conundrum and if we look at the chapter
on everybody keep Hamming on about the
book but if we look at the discipline
and think about okay how do we increase
trust without changing the truth this
isn't about lying to people this is
about using what we've got and to be
more effective
um and we look at the inventive
principles or the psychological
inventive principles funnily enough
they're exactly what we've talked about
signaling I mean what's a small signal
that can help increase believability
that this is going to be the night of my
life what's social proof you're in
um so as you said about Hugh hacking or
I love the term where you went from four
four four breasts to one abreast you're
in that social proof for a boost in
trust and then the third concept is
operational transparency so anything
might be better is having like a live
feed or or
um or you sort of you can see here are
the kegs rolling up right now or maybe
what you're doing and building
anticipation is again making people feel
like they can see the work that's
happening behind the scenes to help them
believe that it's going to be an awesome
night and then we can start there then
we're away I think that the operational
transparency things are an interesting
one because part of what you're trying
to do is make the event sufficiently
exclusive that people can't get access
to it without being there so I know
operational transparency some examples
of that would be a pizzeria that has
flour out front on on the windowsill or
whatever that engenders people to
believe that they're making their own
dough they still might be buying it in
but they've just got some yeah flower
outside and but yeah I wonder what
perhaps operational transparency would
have been included in Here We are
booking the DJs and here we are
addressing the venue here's some photos
of the deck or you know this isn't just
uh you're gonna walk into an empty room
nothing's going to be going on yes one
of the contradictions that you've been
talking about there you say that
Innovation is the resolution of these
contradictions one of the interesting
ones that I've been playing around with
a lot recently is how to Aid decisions
without limiting choice because Barry
Schwartz is the Paradox of choice is
something that I can't unsee anymore and
I keep it just keeps on arising in front
of me for the people that haven't seen
it it's this great Ted Talk that you
should absolutely listen to for maybe 10
or 15 years ago Barry uses this example
of all of the different types of genes
that are available now compared with 50
years ago there was one type of genes
you go in you buy a type of genes the
utilitarian rationalists would say Well
if you get to have as many choices and
options as possible that allows you to
maximize the utility that you can get
because it is much more precise to what
exactly what you wanted but it doesn't
account for the fact that humans have
loss aversion and choice anxiety and all
of this stuff that just they can't bear
the decision and it causes paralysis by
analysis people walk out of the store
having bought no genes and also feeling
ashamed at the fact that they couldn't
choose a pair as opposed to going in and
just having one so the Paradox of
decision versus choice is something I
think that is really prevalent given how
many decisions and opportunities and
options people have now so what are some
of the solutions how can we help people
to make a decision without limiting
their choice too much
so if we imagine our sort of our Matrix
at the end so if we think of aiding
decisions without limiting Choice
um then there are three areas that and
and this is the the start of the
conversation at the end of the
conversation but three areas we explore
looking at defaults looking at at
prompts or or helping people to actually
um sort of guiding people in their
decision making and finally chunking so
to start with defaults so defaults are
uh we often see defaults in or think
about defaults in sort of subscription
so you're automatically subscribe
subscribe if you say yes and it's
already pre-tipped that box in most
circumstances we find that again people
have sort of overloaded with information
that if we can create a system or create
an environment that elicits our desired
choice or or an individual's beneficial
Choice as a direct outcome then that's
setting the default
um so I think in in in in in Disneyland
they change the default menu on on the
kids meals from from chips to Apples and
from soda to orange juice I mean people
could still order soda people could
still
um buy buy chips but the default the
default was was now apples and juice and
it changed the caloric it's already the
the intake significantly just by
changing the default the way that it's
set up because it requires someone to
make an alternative decision
and and there's a few things about
defaults one is that it yes it's sort of
the line of best fit the other is that
it almost feels like it's it's creating
a normal like if you do this you're some
sort of deviant what you want chips for
your kids you you're in it even simply
like in the book I reference
um a uh like a tap faucet in a in a
shower somewhere it's either in in Japan
or in the UK the UK is an amazing place
every shower is different I mean it
blows my mind because someone's house in
the UK person you need to ask for shower
instructions but it had a single number
it said 38 degrees you're in 38 degrees
and then it was sort of warmer or colder
than that but it just said 38 degrees
and then you see like well if I don't
want 38 like I'm breaking the what what
does that say about me I mean so it just
creates this assumption that that's the
desired outcome so so long and short of
it is that um to Aid decision making
without limiting choice we can start to
change the defaults
um so that's a default either that that
helps someone have
um more apples than they do have chips
in in a restaurant all the way through
to research that's looked at organ
donation and opt-in and opt out forms
but the second area that we explore
there in decision making is actually
starting to to help pre-fill some of the
information for people in advance so
people can sort of see or or remove what
is a difficult decision
um the the example I open up on
um and it's not the same as cocoa Pepsi
kind of choice it's sort of what am I
going to do in this scenario
um the example I I start with in the in
the book is an instance
um when a best mates mother sadly passed
away and I was about to send flowers and
I was sort of at that point in the the
online journey to leave a message
and I'm terrible at those things
um but there was an option to have just
some prompts or some inspiration just a
couple of small prompts that was like
just help kick it off and just aided
that Aid of that process
um and it was a lovely example of where
I I could have bought flowers gone
through with that or I might have been
stuck in this paralysis of a different
of complexity paralysis more of a social
paralysis
um we see that through to young children
playing puzzles where we sort of help
them to decide which piece goes where by
embossing the the image in the bottom of
the puzzle we can see oh that's the
giraffe because actually there's a
little picture of the giraffe in the
space too you know so we can just we can
just see that and that goes all the way
through to pre-filling forms for
University enrollment so just giving
someone a little nudge in the right
direction or just prompting someone with
name or or email rather than two empty
boxes I mean that's the extreme of it
um that that can help us and the last um
is is around chunking and I'm racing
through this at a million miles an hour
but I want to sort of cut of them if I
can is looking at chunking and we can
use chunky in two different ways to to
Aid decision making
um one is sort of as we expect so so
chunking is a term used to sort of
breaking up large pieces of information
into small and meaningful chunks we
often see this in mobile phone numbers
where they're sort of chunked into sort
of four digit Series so you sort of
remember the pattern I think the UK
postal codes
I think the the Royal Mail did a survey
that said actually many people find
their postcodes more easy to remember
than their spouse's birthday or their
anniversary they're designed to be
memorable based on how they're chunked
but if we think of chunking often go to
like how does a restaurant help you add
decisions I mean they could just list
everything alphabetically but inside
have the chicken after the after the
beef as I go back to my but and then
you'd have the the ice cream before the
the
um again tap dancing with examples but
it doesn't meaningfully Chunk Up the
menu but but what they do do is chunk it
up into entrees Mains desserts they
might even chunk it up into the proteins
you have chicken seafood or beef so
they're chunking in a meaningful way
when you get your
um your flat pack from Ikea it doesn't
just say okay now make it and it it
chunks down the process into meaningful
steps so that's one way in which we can
add decision chunking up large pieces of
information uh into smaller meaningful
pieces the the element of chunking that
I find even more interesting is when you
actually start to to
make what is a deceptively Simple Choice
a larger decision so you're actually a
add chunks right so
um the the best example that I've come
across of this is is looking at the
presumption of innocence in in legal
cases
um and the burden of proof and
oftentimes you might imagine well
they're either guilty or not guilty but
what many legal firms do is they
actually just map up the burden of proof
so it's it's sort of innocent to highly
likely innocent there's a there's a list
of sort of nine steps you need to go
through before you actually go to guilty
Beyond Reasonable Doubt so it sort of
expands this decision-making process so
you actually need to go through nine
levels of Innocence before you get to
guilt right so it's actually sort of
chunked up what seems like a binary
decision into a multiple multiple stages
in the Physical Realm we see that on the
London Tube we see the sort of the
designated standing areas on the tube
um what is the what is the area that's
deemed to be safe and what is the area
that's a little bit dangerous and what
is the sort of the mind the gap you're
in that's just it's paint it has the
same it's it's this it's the same
platform but it's been chunked down and
it's levels of dangerous you you look at
a hypertension chart they break down
normal into low normal normal and high
normal I mean if I was normal but
they've just created a level of like
high normal so you better start worrying
like don't get too complacent here high
normal and and I just I love that when
we discussed about creating value or
defining a world to help people to
navigate
um it's it's it's a rich there's a rich
world out there I feel like I mean this
is the I feel like I'm doing a lot of
talking here Chris I hope it's okay
that's why you are here Sam that's why
you're the specialist you you've just
mentioned about restaurants and
restaurant experiences yeah I mentioned
that I'd just gone to Rome I noticed
something for a while
that all of my rich friends as soon as
they ascended out of the working class
and into the lower echelons of the
beautiful Stratosphere that is the
middle class all started drinking
sparkling water when we went out for
dinner right and I haven't got a [ __ ]
clue what's going on and it was saying
to them what what is it what is it is
there some secret Mason Society
handshake thing that goes on where
everybody accepts that you've got to
start ordering San Pellegrino as soon as
you get to the table and then I found
myself ashamedly at the start of this
year I found myself ordering a topo
Chico which is a Mexican sparkling water
and it's if you think that you don't
like sparkling water I challenge you to
have a topo Chico and think that it's
not good yeah that was a petersonian
solution because uh Jordan and Michaela
and the rest of their family are
allergic to everything so for them to
have an alcoholic drink they need to
have vodka with
well what can we have it with we need to
have it with something but water would
be insane but somehow a vodka Topo Chico
just doesn't feel too too ridiculous my
point being what do you think is going
on why is it
that rich people like to drink Sparkling
Water and didn't you look at the top of
a San Pellegrino the lid of a San
Pellegrino as well
yes I I think I mean there could be two
sides to this one is the individual the
other is the restaurant so I think
there's again if we're talking about
signals of opulence and and wealths like
paying for water sort of is is is is
itself it's like the peacock feather
it's like oh this waste that I can
afford I mean there's a signal of my
gravitas and fitness right so at an
individual level paying for water might
provide sort of more social status that
does hydration the other side could be
actually the restaurants that
um you frequent with
um if friends in in the stratospheric
middle class
um have a have a placebo choice they
might say do do you want Perrier or
sparkling yeah I don't even offer you
tap so either way you're having
sparkling are you having you're having
bottled water of some sort um so it
could be it could be driven by the
restaurant could be driven by the
individual but
um but it's it's what's interesting is
that it happens it's predictable and and
if you understand whether or not it's
again this opulence of
um of of of of paying for something
slightly needlessly then that provides
these that these evolved sort of status
queues well again my background in
Nightlife conspicuous consumption was a
uh very very common you know the biggest
bottle of vodka you know that five guys
aren't even going to be able to get
through half of it by the end of the
evening and it's they're pouring it over
their watches or they're giving away
glasses for free or they're spraying
champagne this is all conspicuous
consumption happening right yeah and I
wonder whether yeah the the
unnecessary expensive you see this with
Vos have you said you know VOS
yeah beautiful beautiful packaging yeah
well-designed bottle it's very standout
why would you need a standout bottle of
of water it's just water why isn't it
more utilitarian it's completely
circular which means it's like a a
cylinder which means it's actually quite
difficult to pack away if you were to
ever take it anywhere it would be easier
to have something like evolvik which has
got maybe rounded edges but is more kind
of cubic and rectangular well the reason
is that everybody knows even if they
haven't seen the logo if they see the
silhouette of the bottle they know that
that's a bottle of water that costs
seven pounds so that makes sense what
did am I right in thinking you looked at
something to do with the lid of San
Pellegrino or did I make that up we
often explode we off today
um as a as an organization we often talk
about the the lid of the same Pellegrino
the the the costly signal again the
waste of the tin foil on a sand
Pellegrino again it's it's just a subtle
a subtle nod to the fact that we've
invested enough in this product to
justify the investment of a little bit
more to have it sealed off with with
aluminum that changed recently I think
they've actually taken away the the tin
foil
the uh turtles and the tortoises and
stuff we can't be wastefully costly well
in some instances to change the change
the bottom line you know and it's it's
hard
I wonder how much I wonder how many
companies are using the Eco I I've said
this for ages I mean you must have seen
this if you've been traveling anywhere
hotels are absolutely riding off of
they're playing this perfect balance
between covid and uh the green movement
in order to not come and clean your room
but no [ __ ] you like I know why you're
doing this you're not doing this because
you care about the environment you're
doing this because you've been able to
half your cleaning costs over the last
three years yeah yeah there are two and
again it's and uh totally I've just just
been away actually and you can see it
and it was via the airport
um which was just Madness whenever we
understand aviation's been hit so hard
but you sort of seeing about a
commercial a commercial outcome but I
think for for
um for for
sem Pellegrino I I think it's it can be
hard on a spreadsheet to justify a
useless piece of tinfoil if you don't
understand what it does for you at a
psychological level
um again that sometimes we often say
sort of the
marketers wonder where sort of what 50
of your your advertising is wasted and
actually the wasted proportion might be
the most valuable bit you know it shows
that you've got money to burn to bring
your product if you've got money to burn
to bring your product to the market then
people must be buying it
um it's rare for for failing products or
to to have a Super Bowl commercial I'd
suggest you're in uh otherwise how do
you afford it
um so it's so it's this so Sam
Pellegrino is a lovely example of a
costly signal to help you just like
white gloves in a wedding dress it's a
little bit of investment to help you
trust that what goes within the Box
what's underneath the foil is of is of
quality otherwise we wouldn't be
protecting it
um it's a it's a lovely piece there that
is a really nice Insight around the cost
of marketing overall and the stuff that
maybe doesn't drive clicks or
conversions on the back end or whatever
so with brands that I work with for the
podcast or whatever they're looking to
try and track whether or not people are
interested in the products that I'm
talking about I'm like well I use them I
would hope that the people that listen
to the show you're interested as well
but a big chunk of it is well
how do you put a value on being
associated with Jordan Peterson's name
on Joker willink's name or that these
are the sort of brand associations that
are very difficult to buy literally you
can't buy them these people aren't for
sale so yeah how do you try and quantify
that well you don't does it show up on
the balance sheet well
I don't know maybe aggregated and
smeared across the next five years
across a bunch of purchases that are
tiny little nudges towards decisions and
blah blah but yeah it's it's very
interesting thinking about that the
other uh contradiction that I thought
that was super interesting to me was
improving experience without changing
duration because our passive
um subjective experience of time is
something that I've always been pretty
fascinated with and the way that we can
speed that up and slow it down Rory's
example about the innovation of uber
wasn't the fact that you could order it
from anywhere it's that you knew how
long it was going to be until the taxi
arrived I'm pretty sure that Ogilvy was
it you guys that got brought in to
reduce complaints at security in
Heathrow and you did that by putting
signs saying 60 minutes from here 45
minutes from here 30 minutes from here
and previously it was an engineering
problem that was going to be or we need
to put we can have a different type of
scanning system and the belt can go at
four miles per hour quicker and we'll
have a whatever no it's not an
engineering problem a psychology problem
so using your new framework your Tris
mapped across onto psychology what about
experience and duration did you learn
well I mean the first thing that I
learned is what is what you touched from
the beginning
um that was a fascinating part of
research in the book was about the
malleability of of our experience of
time
all the way through to looking into
species that a fly experiences time much
faster than than we do in a and a whale
experience is it more slowly than we do
and it sort of makes sense how do they
know how fast they did so have you ever
seen have you ever seen like a um a TV
being filmed by a camera you know and
the camera picks up the flickers of a TV
yeah
so so I I don't understand the
technology behind it but the processing
speed of the camera is maybe faster than
this so you so you see what the eyes cut
essentially so what they did was they
they put electrodes on a series of of
many different animals
um and and showed them different
speeds of flickering light and if if an
animal could see the flicker then that
could show that their processing speed
was faster right
um because I think that's I think that
and I don't know this as a fact but I
think they said the dogs might be able
to see the flicker but we can't see the
flicker so so I'm not 100 on that but
that's that's the way in which they
explored how they could do this
um and and it sort of it makes sense
from an evolutionary perspective as well
like it's no benefit for a whale to see
the world faster than it can act upon
if it says if a whale was to see the
world as fast as a flight would just be
like sort of depressed all the time
because it can't do anything about it
um whereas a hawk needs to see the world
faster than a whale because it can sort
of action that so so having these
differences in in in in this species
um experience of time is was I found a
sort of a fascinating piece but then
when we look even within our own species
um that time can be experienced very
differently and a couple of different
things that that can change our
experience of time
um sort of Novel events stress and
pressure and familiarity and so the more
familiar as I said we come earlier sort
of the more we begin to switch off our
attentional resources tend to go down we
don't tend to absorb as much information
our brain is not taking as many photos
all the time it doesn't need to because
we're in a we're in a familiar
environment whereas we're in a novel
environment or under under stress and
pressure or or in danger our brains
looking to capture every element to help
us to survive and that that that that
that
focus of resources extends our
experience of time and they find this
sort of experimentally through different
paradigms one thing is called the
Oddball effect so you might see a series
of cows flicking on a screen and then
they'll throw up an apple in and people
will say that the Apple was on the
screen longer than the cows and it
wasn't at the exact same time but
because your sort of brain starts to
switch off and not need to read as much
information of the cows this new image
of an apple sort of focuses your
attention and stretches that time
whereas we also can forget putting out
the rubbish and catching our train for
the gazillionth time so I found that
anyway just broadly a fascinating area
so a couple of things
um that we look at one is about
expectation that be having an
expectation of an outcome we can change
the experience duration so if we're
waiting
um without information on coming then
that time feels extended I mean we feel
uncomfortable we social stressed
therefore we're laying more of these of
these memories the time feels it's sort
of extended
um when we we are having a sense of
expectation of what to experience then
that time goes faster so one and my
partner and I were talking about this
recently we did a we did a it was a
really dangerous Bush walk to we have a
four-year-old and a one-year-old we've
got we got sort of halfway and thought
geez I wish we didn't do this but on on
the way back we sort of thought that was
faster than the way out and there's it's
called the return trip effect and often
people experience that the outgoing
journey is longer than the the Homewood
Journey
um so you might be feel like it takes a
long time to get to a particular
destination but it's faster coming back
and one of the the justifications for
this is now we have set our expectations
to how long the trip is
um we know how far we're going to go so
it's going to be faster when we're
coming home again so so providing
someone with a sense of expectation of
outcome again whether it's 60 minutes 40
minutes and we can start to shift that I
think
um in in Disneyland they tend to over
inflate the expected times and say you
wait for an hour but it's really 40
minutes because you're just sort of
shaping expectations
um so expectation management is is the
first the the the second is basically
just engaging the brain um with activity
so so one of the biggest
um culprits of it sort of experience
duration is boredom and again another
fascinating
um one whereas when we're bored we often
think that we're sort of just like doing
nothing but when we're bored we're
actually really stressed uh our our
brain and our body is telling us to do
something else you know it's it's it's
because we have less
um reproductive or social benefits of
sitting there doing nothing so when
we're actually bored we're really
stressed when we're stressed time slows
down so it's like a double whammy so
just engaging the brain and whether
that's the classic
um mirrors on in an elevator that help
people sort of to them to look at their
makeup or do their tie
um that's that's a great example of just
engaging engaging the brain and we can
see elevators around the world putting
in little games and things like that now
just to keep us occupied while we're
waiting while we're traveling now all
the way to the extreme of the Eurostar
um that um created a a wonderful AI mask
for kids right in between London and
Paris but as you go under the tunnel you
put the sort of the mask on and um and
you're transported to this foreign World
under this under the sea and before you
know it you've popped up on the other
side so rather than sitting there bored
you're just sort of engaging the brain
tricking it into believing that it's
experiencing some other sort of social
social benefit
um and the last is looking at at the the
what's known as the peak end effect the
peak and and how it how it ends and
funnily enough this was also brought up
over the over the last week was my part
and when we talked about our trip and
and the peak
um experience
um certainly this bushwalk but we tend
to remember events based on their Peak
how extremely positive or negative they
are and how they end
um and so if we can start to manufacture
more Peaks and and positive endings and
that's not necessarily lifting the
average experience from a six to a seven
that's fine like what are some
opportunities to sprinkle in some more
tens then we can again and boost the
experience without actually changing its
duration
another nightlife example for you here
please we used to so during the evening
we would have an event schedule the
schedule would be stuff like confetti
drop at midnight and balloon drop at 12
30 and Stage games at 1 15 or whatever
yes uh so that was Peaks right and the
Peaks are often we leave that up to the
DJ mostly that combined with a little
bit of production but one of the things
we realized is if we gave people a
little a little treat on the way out
that would maximize the end effect as
well because everybody has to leave and
some people are leaving early because
they've bagged off with a partner for
the night or maybe because they've had a
little bit too much to drink so they
don't maybe need one and we actually
managed to combine two really great
strategies here
one of the issues you have in most
cities is that nightclubs are not a
million miles away from residential
areas and although the night clubs
themselves will be sufficiently
soundproofed to avoid leakage going out
above the decibel level that is for the
noise pollution you can't mandate the
same for the people that leave the
patrons that leave go outside and they
start doing football chants and they
start screaming and shouting at each
other and recording tick tocks so what
we did
to combine both of these was we gave
people lollipops on the way out just
nice little lollipops and there was
someone handing them to them rather than
the bucket because the bucket just
didn't feel like a nice experience it
was a pretty girl or a good looking lad
and he would be handing out oh there you
go there's a lollipop the lollipop was
the end effect it made them feel like
they've been well treated it was given
out by somebody that left a good Lasting
Impression and because you're sucking on
a lollipop you're not going to start
chanting because you've got some sugar
in your mouth wonderful so we managed to
come up with a search for that as well
and that's a cracker and again and this
is why I find because I've not explored
the the world of of optimizing an
evening this is where you missed now we
should but having having a balloon drop
I mean that's a that's a that's a a
wonderful like again Peak memorable
moment oh [ __ ] sorry I'm going to give
you another one I'm gonna give you
another one so imagine that you're in a
big a a bigger club we haven't done this
for a while because you need a venue
that's got a very high ceiling and a big
dance floor
you'll remember if you're a sports game
and there is a single beach ball being
battered around you're more concerned
with what's going on with the beach
balls sometimes yes than what's going on
on the pitch the match yeah so we
realized that you could basically do the
same thing and we uh created
created we stole this from a bunch of
festivals
um moderate weight balloons that are
massive they're sort of like bigger than
a beach ball a couple of feet across we
would inflate those and we would knock
those out into the crowd and then we
would light them from the back so that
as you were seeing these balloons go
through the air there were just these
the club would be pretty dark except for
some light striking the balloons and it
was just an unbelievable way to keep
people occupied and you would see exits
would be reduced during that time what
you're trying to do is not only get the
crowd in but hold the crowd as well
because you don't want people to leave
to go elsewhere and you would see the
number of people going to the bathroom
would be reduced the number of people
that were leaving would be reduced
because they were mesmerized and maybe
they got the opportunity to hit it and
yeah that was no it's cool it's a
wonderful canvas
um to consider and the more distinctive
and fun again the more more memorable
every car has a sports mode but only
Tesla has ludicrous mode you I mean it's
just uh there's a in the book I write
it's actually from Chip and Dan Heath's
um they've found it for for the power of
moments it's a it's a hotel in Los
Angeles it's really sort of a clap tap
old old old hotel it's called The Magic
Castle Hotel
um but it ranks I've been there on have
you been to the Magic Castle I managed
to sneak myself an invite a few years
ago perfect and and so so you'll know
better than me then what they have is is
a tell us what's the what's the most
memorable feature of the Magic Castle
Hotel
um you whisper to an owl to get in I
think is it an hour I feel like it's a
statue of an owl and you need to go up
and whisper to it and then this sliding
bookcase opens up uh no phones no
nothing else so that that was that
created an anticipatory effect that or
this is something that's special it's
confidential
um upon going in maybe this is the owl I
can't remember there's there's a thing
that you can go and Whisper a song to
and if you whisper a song to it the
piano that has nobody sat in front of it
starts playing the song that you just
whispered that was cool that was pretty
insane I know there was just loads of so
I ended up getting pretty uh pretty
drunk that night so my memory my memory
is I get further into the evening
becomes more hazy but yeah it was it was
spectacular but you're not worried that
the most important thing is you're not
worried about the thread count you're
not worried about sort of whether your
towels are left on the hook or should I
you mean it's it's you're thinking about
you're thinking about the the whispering
owl that the the the the the strange
piano there's a apparently there's a
button beside the pool that you oh
there's a there's a phone a little phone
box you you lift up and you ask it's a
popsicle hotline and if you lift up the
phone someone away to with a with a sort
of a silver platter will bring you a
free popsicle to the pool so it's again
it's just adding these moments of
distinctiveness and and and and that
boosts memorability and it's it's not
again every touch point from six to
seven it's finding these things that
that create more action velcro for the
brain I think maybe there's an argument
to be made that malmesan
have a good end effect to their customer
experience I think that they literally
had a sign below the toiletries saying
the best toiletries that you'll ever
steal
yeah and there's another one it says the
same from Virgin Atlantic on the on the
bottom of this salt and pepper it says
stolen from Virgin Atlantic and it's
it's wonderful stuff and and and it's
it's and this is where I say there's
sort of similar examples you can have a
popsicle hotline of the at the at the
the Magic Castle Hotel in La there's Bob
Bob Rickards in SoHo in London that has
a press for champagne button you know
it's really simpler kind of Concepts but
they just again they they'd spark the
brain they capture more memories you're
in and therefore they can start to shape
the memory of the experience rather than
the the the the the the actual
experience because we navigate by the
memory of it not the the time itself I
mean that's fleeting but how we recall
it is is more powerful last thing um
your lollipop solution there's another
piece of innovation that you might have
found that also you reduced fights
um there's a evidence around sugar
consumption and aggression particularly
on alcohol I mean there's a there's a
group of Volunteers in in Sydney called
the Red Frog Brigade and they walk
around the nightclubs handing out red
frogs just to sort of boost glucose the
red frogs like a lot of Red Frog or so
maybe that's it's a lolly so it's a
maybe it's an Australia a classic
Australia it's like a like a lolly but
again having a bit of sugar doesn't just
sort of stop the stop people from
shouting it probably actually stops
people from from being aggressive and
maybe they're both connected anyway
because you're not yelling abuse at
someone who's sucking on a chopper chap
some Tatum ladies and gentlemen if
people want to check out the stuff that
you do where should they go
uh look at me on on LinkedIn on on
Twitter I think it's s underscore Tatum
t-a-t-a-m uh if you're interested check
out the book evolutionary ideas on
Amazon all good booksellers
um it's been a a labor of love and and
really fun to sort of talk through some
of the elements of it I've really
enjoyed this conversation mate thank you
fun I appreciate you cheers mate what's
happening people thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that episode
then press here for a selection of the
best clips from the podcast over the
last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
face
[Music]